what's the procedure what do we do
people are dead oh how did that happen
it's out in the hall no we don't know
that the smoke could be coming through
an air duct oh my god okay it's
happening everybody stay calm
everyone what's the procedure
down
first things first oven mitts
where are the oven mitts oh my god they
have all the as seen on tv stuff oh
shake weight iron gym miracle hand
repair big top cookie pillow putts slap
chop honey we gotta go over here honey
listen to me
get it all
grab everything that we've seen it on tv
put it in this cart right now
iron gym
i am gonna get so bopped we got a fire
yeah
i've seen that this is taking too long
i'm gonna miss the farmer's market
love love fades away but things
things are forever that's beautiful did
the dalai lama say that oh
a citrus reamer ah this is the only way
to reap citrus you're gonna need two of
these
cheese
things can be replaced phyllis people
human lives however can
because they're acting all tough and
everything but what they were rapping
about was cupcakes the chronicles of
narnia uh who invented cupcakes right i
want to kill hey hey hey phyllis what
are you doing i'm just saying hi to bob
no i think you're cutting in line well
settle down scott no i'm not gonna
settle down no way uh-uh get in the back
please
[Music]
this is pretzel day
i hate black friday
nypd everyone down ma'am if you could
just get down or ignore me and continue
shopping welcome to nirvana the plaza at
eagleton there's a reflecting pull out
back there's an old-timey train that
runs through the mall and three
burberries if you tell your friend hey
meet me at burberries they gotta specify
which one
let's hit it
i really want this dress and i like this
crystal beetle but it's expensive and
there's no use for it
don
amigo treat yourself
velvet slippies cashmere socks velvet
pants cashmere turtle i'm a cashmere
velvet candy cane treat yourself
i mean this is insane
wow all right everybody get ready store
is set to open in exactly one minute 60
59. you don't have to say all the
numbers 60
61. yeah that's right i'm going up now
okay uh one last thought before we open
that
yes you can get pregnant from that ankle
you can get pregnant from any angle
what
no i can't i can't hear you
if i could just get everybody describing
what black friday means to them that
would be no kate that's a new camera
we're trapped everyone for himself okay
let's go all right let's go get out of
my way
have you ever seen a burn victim
okay
procedural procedure hey guys
i'm really feeling these sheets very
cozy
we should probably head back yeah okay
oh
i dare you to make an announcement you
dare me how old are you
just quit snowing
lou
this is your father
come set the table for dinner
such a dork
jim helper
price check on fabric softener to kind
of bounce please don't touch that that
is not a toy i'm sorry
sorry
how old are you
i hate you
[Music]
[Music]
move it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
aisle seven 30 days home and garden very
factory farm we don't sell wigs anymore
pistachio color
heather reconfigure the lpos and then
move them to the prc
henry get all the upts out of the green
zone if you run into a jam radio a 62
feet for a dvr got it
all right break
wow yeah that was impressive you know
had it in me i mean none of it meant
anything but the confidence is inspiring
have a heavenly day
next attention shoppers the store is now
closed not like bring your items to the
front clothes i mean like get the hell
out
thank you
oh also if anyone happens to find a
little green hair thing it's mine
thank you so much for shopping at cloud9
oh sir you accidentally drove over my
daughter's door not accidentally
i hate black friday
i can't move
me neither
hey myrtle
myrtle
could somebody poke myrtle and see if
she's still alive
you